haris i'm not getting your texts if you
keep on texting me
it's not happening i'm trying my best
man you i mean it's just no reception i
had some [ __ ] to say to you
it's all right i'll tell you another
time are you doing today sir
i'm good man i love your background
that's so cool
uh it's a distraction for this and it
works
honestly it does i got it how you doing
man
listen i'm doing great i'm super happy
to be talking to you about fast nine or
f9 i'm sorry
uh i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie
so can you share something that maybe
people might be surprised to learn
about the making of f9
um well
the london london is um it's a very
challenging place to make a movie
um the overcast the weather
the rain for this to have always been
traditionally
a film where you have
cars and energy and action and summer
i mean it's so much more dangerous to do
what it is that we do when the grounds
are constantly wet
and there's no sun
shining in the sky and you have to
set up that many more lights to
overcompensate for what's not
in the sky
and the time zone difference wears on
you
being that far away from the u.s
so i think a lot of us
um who are from the us
found that challenging because i think
we did six
in the uk and then we came back to do
nine in the uk so it was challenging
to to tell this story and and do
what it is that we did this round
um in london it was very challenging
how much have you pulled aside justin
and vin have been like so tell me
everything about fast10
um i have definitely asked some
questions about 10 and 11.
and it it has been confirmed
that we are going to shoot back to back
and get both in the can
um which
is interesting um
and um
i'm hearing that we're going to touch a
lot of continents
between the two i cannot say
where but a lot
and i think
the higher-ups that are involved in this
franchise
are specifically aware of the die-hard
fans and supporters around the world
and we all carry a particular torch
of responsibility and knowing that there
is a beast
and we got to feed that beast and give
them
what they want what they love and what
they're used to
uh i have so many questions i'm uh i
wanna
i'm debating between two i'm gonna ask
you about filming the space stuff just
because
i loved it and i just wanna know to
share what it was like filming
the outer space stuff just because it's
[ __ ] great
uh well i can't really speak on it um
got a bit of a gag order in place so i
don't know what you're talking about
can i let me add something different
that you can't answer i loved your
speech
in the movie where you're talking about
what is like
we don't get hurt this is crazy like
there's this whole thing
and i love that was that in the script
is that you
talk about filming that yes um
i have to give his give him the credit
that is justin lin
and the writer um who
introduced this concept here's the thing
roman pierce has always said
and addressed what likely the audience
is thinking
and so there's nobody in the movie
that could have talked about that but me
and i think when you
call it out it allows for you
to stop overthinking that ain't real
that's unrealistic that's [ __ ] it
gets you out of that
and it just allows for you to enjoy the
[ __ ] movie
you know eat some popcorn laugh
cheer root have some fun and whatever
amount of money whatever euros you're
spending whatever country you're in
just know that there's two hours and 20
minutes that belongs to us
and when you give it to us we're gonna
over deliver
and have you having a great time
this world has unleashed unbearable
amounts of stress and trauma on all of
us
and i think what has been interesting
about the success
for thus far in f9 is it's really a
reflection
of where where we are
and what we all are coming out of now
with covet you know we were all in fear
of something that we didn't understand
what is it what do we do what we don't
do
just craziness and
i think carving out two hours
of your life and going to see fast
is going to be the best therapy session
that you didn't know you you needed
i have to stop seriously thank you so
much for talking with me
i hope it's a huge hit i appreciate you
you're gonna see
it that it's a huge hit man everybody's
looking at this interview baby
right exactly thanks man have a great
day thank you